yeah welcome to this video a new game
against um Jo going bush here on Bush
wash I'm doing really battle with his
name okay I'm playing the scotch and I'm
not really sure why I just put it on the
boardwalk try to pronounce the name okay
I play plating before he's the he's the
main guy behind those SOS books and
secret of opening surprises and I went
for the the phone night Siena lat d
success an interesting alternative to to
d5 setups the ideas here exactly this a
direct attack i played this myself a
couple of times and it's it is fairly
interesting um cannot really remember
night a form quite often this is a good
idea to make sure to get the bishop that
it cannot go to c5 you attack it with
gc3 be forms things like that
if he goes Queen to h4 which is not so
ridiculous it's a yeah I intended Bishop
f4 yeah this must be right but be very
surprised if this is the wrong with
covering age two and then tanning Bishop
d3 at at some stage ya know it's it
looks like em it looks like a bit a bit
crude but it's I played the stuff myself
I mean it's not it's not so terrible
Bishop g3 c 3 a 3 all kinds of stuff
maybe a three and before
ok let's go here first then to try to
try to play out somewhat quicker to try
to get into big-time time pressure here
so before and takes you ok I want to get
rid of this Bishop the a porn is not
exactly great but cannot have everything
so
95 to see for you might be might be an
idea
maybe I can can try to use the apron Wow
yeah I know he had this is sometimes
really possible I only didn't expect it
him
g5 I probably taken play Quincy one
yeah before was just hanging what what
else could a plane
yeah don't like it I really don't like
it I try to get some activity here and
I'm so passive I want to go Quinn b7
after others try to to to put some
pressure here on its paws it's probably
not great anyway you can just press five
hmm Bishop c4
not sure that this really helps
now off into play maybe queen bee six
now you can play Queen B 6 and maybe
then i need to add this one you're also
not bad maybe bishop basics not that
it's particularly threatening
yeah I'm threatening to take n play
Bishop v70 XC six but I can most play
okay too and the process
k
not sure how does he approve we probably
has some way to improve but maybe I can
go here tending look look be five maybe
oh man I'm so slow it's it's it's
absolutely amazing
I can just take the rook no kids drop it
back I should have taken you to this was
much easier much easier hi morning
18 seconds smooth
the id-5 for snow is saying and probably
wookie
check
yeah okay it's a it's an end game with
the really bad time situation
white working yeah no chance to get to
this I only need three moves now to get
rid of the porn but was soon I spend far
too much time before and it was a crap
game anyway I was in trouble and then he
just blunted everything I mean good as
it was all so much easier to just take
it to now I mean it's an extra book and
now I'm he made agates it's a rook and I
actually should win I mean 13 seconds
it's not much but it's probably doable
yeah anyway thanks for watching